what do you actually think is the future
for someone like Don Lemon at this point
you want me to tell you yeah you ready
for this answer yeah it's Tom you're
gonna like this answer Don lemon's
future is to go to any network that
needs a great Dei score 100
you're right you're right yes or no
you're right that lemon's gonna go to
any network that needs to improve their
di yeah
that's right he's a he's a Dei score
candidate what are the what's the
likelihood that Don ends up on Fox and
he's like the old Juan Williams one
black guy Democrat just getting
lambasted uh by the rest of the the team
over there on the five I don't see Don
Lemon as a hard-working guy who research
stories books I don't see him as that
guy
don't get this far without doing your
work
first of all he's it's very hard to look
that good he's a very good looking guy
good talker you know extremely confident
in himself very confident in himself he
is a guy that's like he just he he looks
at himself as a uh what do you call it
as a superstar but there's a ward for it
he looks at himself as a
um I'm somebody he thinks aliens of
himself he's got a very Larger than Life
confidence in himself that's Don Lemon
no but Don Lemon is not I don't see Don
Lemon being Chris Cuomo I think Chris
Cuomo was Kris Cuomo he was a
heavyweight I think Chris Cuomo studied
I think Chris Cuomo called his brother I
think Chris Cuomo stayed up reading
articles I think Chris Cuomo got up
early to work out and read every article
and saw everything that everybody said
on Twitter the day before I see him
doing that I saw Chris Cuomo doing that
I even think madal does that I think
Morning Joe does that I don't think he
does that but I think he's a little bit
lazier and I don't think Don's gonna
find a network like CNN that I mean for
all that time watches your ass and mind
you you know how Sassy he'd be on air
somebody would say something he's like
listen oh you can walk out I'll cut you
off the air right now he's not going to
find a place like that so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]